I battled depression and anxiety my
whole life I think I found writing and
Performing as a way of um of dealing
with that particularly humor a lot of
the kids would go to a traditional sleep
camp that was about sports and I I
didn't I didn't shine and I and I felt
alienated and I was like what's wrong
with me my parents found this theater
camp for me that was called Stage Door
Manor and I went there and it was like
epiphanous it was Utopia it was a place
where everyone was a performer and
everyone was like me and I didn't know
that there were other kids that many
kids out there like me that's why I
became a writer and a filmmaker was a
way of was a way of trying to find
shared Community with these feelings
that I have it's most cathartic when I
finally watch it with an audience and I
see their reaction when they laugh at
the right moment when they swipe a tear
at the right moment when their pin drops
silent at the right moment that's when I
feel like
oh I'm not alone in these emotions it's
an antidote to loneliness